So the,
the other aspect of water that we have to think about besides the,
um,
you know,
just the,
the sheer values of it or the sheer amounts of it are the quality.
So you guys probably saw this out of the green chemistry theory and practice
that you don't really need much of a toxic substances to pollute very large
amounts of water.
So,
you know,
a huge problem with like
dripping oil from cars and things.
If it gets into water supplies,
you can essentially ruined very large amounts of water very quickly.
And this is a big problem for a lot of chemical manufacturers that just a little
bit of byproduct can ruin a water streams for communities and large parts of the
country.
Uh,
in the United States we have pretty good numbers on aqueous waste from the toxic
release inventory.
Hazardous waste is,
um,
not,
uh,
a huge piece of the pie,
but it's pretty substantial.
I mean,
it's 675 million tons per year.
So there's a,
a lot of hazardous waste wastewater being generated and uh,
you know,
for the most part,
a lot of basic chemicals are dealt with in water treatment systems,
but a lot we're increasingly finding that a lot or not,
if you go looking for more chemicals,
you often find them.
So the US Geological Survey did this survey of um,
water supplies and natural sources in the United States a couple of years ago
and they were finding something like 80% of the sites that they looked at were
containing these different chemicals.
Uh,
so,
you know,
[inaudible] and bug spray,
bisphenol a,
flame retardants,
all kinds of things.
Um,
not all of this is coming from runoff.
Uh,
a lot of these followup research has shown that these things just get through
waste treatment plants because a lot of these chemicals were not around when the
waste treatment plant technology was devised.
And so we're kind of running experiments on ourselves that,
uh,
basically humans and other animals and ecosystems are serving as the,
the filters for these,
these,
uh,
boy streams.
So I just touched on that.
I mean you can have point contamination of water.
I mean this is kind of the obvious thing.
If you see like a sewer pipe spewing nasty water,
that's a point contamination.
But then there's also things like agricultural runoff,
um,
leaking of septic tanks and sewer systems and mine drainage.
And how this ties back into energy is that if you're able to capture these,
um,
wastes sources,
the main way of dealing with them is typically some sort of chemical process.
So,
uh,
given that we're all,
you know,
in,
in an oxidizing environment,
you know,
we're,
we're in an oxygen pretty much the way to deal with aqueous pollutants is to try
and oxidize them.
And a lot of waste treatment plants and processes are trying to basically
combust the chemicals in water.
So kind of fired water.
Uh,
all the carbon is going to go to CO2.
Ideally hydrogen and oxygen would go to water.
And then you'd end up with these same kind of nitrogen and sulfur oxides that
you might see from burning something and an engine.
And so you have a lot of choices in what types of chemicals would get used in
that,
in those processes.
And all of these,
again,
we'll have different energy impacts.
So treating the water you're going to be choosing between things like chlorine,
you're going to be choosing between,
um,
ozone,
maybe ozone at different Ph is I was on with catalysts,
UV rays,
radiation.
It takes energy to generate UV light hydrogen peroxide.
It's going to take energy to produce hydrogen peroxide.
Um,
the producing the catalyst tio two is one of the most common catalysts.
So extracting tio two,
getting it or extracting titanium,
converting it to tio two,
getting it in a form that can be used in these plants.
All of these things are going to be contributing to energy.
And so again,
we keep saying this,
this energy nexus that um,
there you find tradeoff.
So chlorine and ozone are probably two of the most common water treatment
chemicals.
Uh,
chlorine actually has a lower embedded energy burden than ozone,
but on the other hand,
chlorine is potentially more likely to generate toxic byproducts.
So,
um,
some of the,
the supplemental readings we'd given our about things like when chlorine reacts
with the organic chemicals,
it doesn't always convert the carbon to CO2.
It converts them to carbon chlorine bonds.
And then you end up with organochlorine chemicals that,
uh,
sometimes are worse than the original compound.
Sometimes they accumulate in,
uh,
in animals.
And so these are the kinds of questions that have to get asked when you,
when,
uh,
a chemical processes generating aqueous waste,
if to start thinking about how is it going to get treated and how much water is
it potentially going to affect?
Where's that water going to go?
And is it going to take a lot of energy to deal with that water?